e
[Alkış]
Herkese merhabalar bu
abone ol
Sen hiç böyle garip bir başlık kırkla
Sonuçta başlamak istiyorum
21. yüzyılda herkes ileri gitmekten
bahsediyor Ben geri gitmenin yollarını
anlatacağım Çünkü bazı şeyleri
yapmadığınız takdirde geri gitme
riskiniz var
Birçok genç arkadaş hukukun ötesinden
bahsediyoruz bana ileriden ufkun ötesine
geçtik ne iş yapacağız diye soruyor
açıkçası cevabını bilmiyorum ama bana ne
iş yaparsanız yapın bir şekilde başarılı
olmak için 21 yüzyılda 21 yüzyılın
matematiğini çok iyi anlamamız gerekiyor
çünkü resimde de görüyorsunuz sürat
sürat üzerine konuşacağız bugün çok
süratli bir yüzyılda yaşıyoruz bunu laf
olsun diye söylemiyorum çok duyuyorsunuz
ama gözünüzde canlandırmak için size bir
kira kalmayacağım
Evet şu an Bu salonda bulunan kaç kişi
ise düz kişi izleyelim kabaca tabi
kalabalığız belki ama
ve her kişi için her bir kişi için
saniyede 1.7 megabayt ver üretiliyor
dünyada bu videoya siz üretiyorsunuz ya
da bir şekilde Sizin için size etrafında
çalışan makineler sistemler üretiyor yüz
kişiyi Seiko
bu hesaplaması daha kolay değil
yüzüyorum 170 MB saniyede şu an ver
üretiyor sizin için bu konuşmanın 18
dakika olması planlandı 18 dakika
sonunda
180gb 60 saniyede çarpıyorum şarkı
10880 GB veri üretmiş olacaksınız
ve Bugünkü tedex günü sonuna kadar Red
edilen veri terabayt geçecek farkında
mısınız Ben gençken
o ilk bilgisayarla tanıştık
şu kullandığımız oyun bilgisayarları 64
kilo artık sistem verdi gözünüzde
canlandırmaya açısından söylüyorum
robottan megabayta geçtik megabayttan
GBT bakayım Bugün şu toplantı sonuna
kadar terabayttan bahsediyoruz
ve dolayısıyla bu sürate
ilişmek bu seti doğru anlamak çok önemli
Hatta bakın daha iyi anlamanız şöyle bir
şey söyleyeyim daha belki sürat kısmı
daha iyi anlayacaksınız verilen
büyüklüğü dışında
dünyada üretilen Bugüne kadar bütün
tarih boyunca üretilen verilerin
ama hepsi bir gözünüzde canlandırın
ve onları bir kenara koyup Son iki yılda
üretilen
teknolojinin gelişmesiyle üretilen
birileri düşünün Bunlar birbirine eşit
yani Son iki yılda bugüne kadar dünya
tarihinde üretilen biri kadar ver
üretildi Dünyada böyle bir dünyada
yaşıyoruz ve siz böyle bir Dünyaya
adapte olmaya çalışıyorsunuz dolayısıyla
böyle bir dünyada bir takım şeyleri
yapmadığı takdirde gerçekten geri gitme
ihtimalimiz var ekonomi değişiyor Wars
izin şu an içerisinde yer aldığınız
veyahut gelecekte yer alacağınız
ekonomiye çok iyi anlamanız gerekiyor ve
Star toplardan bahsediyoruz değil mi Her
yerde bir start-up muhabbeti dönüyor
nedir bu Star tatlar biraz Dostlar
toplardan konuşalım öncelikle şunu
söyleyeyim
bu saatte bu resmi bir tanımı yok Herkes
biraz farklı bir şekilde şey yapıyor
Türk hukukunda da yok böyle bir tanımaz
start-up şudur İki nokta üst üste diye
ama sert kapların bazı özellikleri var
size Usta hattatların özelliklerinden
yola çıkarak madem bu kadar duyuyoruz
tatlar onları anlatayım bir start-up var
çok süratli büyüyor bu
var yani ufak bir şirket olup
başlıyorlar işte klasik evin garajında
kurdum şey vardır hikayeleri Biliyorsun
sana çok süratli büyüyorlar dünya
çapında şirketler haline geliyorlar aynı
şekilde Start Up lar çok süratli Global
yaşıyorlar ve Eskiden bir şirket
kurduğunuzda işte mahallede Ticaret
yapardınız büyüdünüz o ilçede bir
yerlerde Ticaret yapardınız bütün şey
ayırdınız olmadı Türkiye'ye ayırdığınız
şimdi buraya birleşmeden bahsediyoruz
bütün dünyayı böyle statlar var ki
dünyada Sizler de bunu sosyal medyada
günlük hayatınızda kullanıyorsunuz
milyarlarca kullanıcı sorbe
o ölçeklenmesi ölçekleme neydi Biraz
teknik biterim ama bilmenizde yarar var
Çünkü artık ekonomide bu çok konuşuluyor
ölçekleme şu demek büyüdüğü oranda sağ
kapağı çok süratli biliyor dedik ya
masrafları ve maliyetleri de aynı oranda
artmıyor bordo lise ekonomik bir şekilde
biliyorlar bu da çok iyi bir şey yani
büyüdüğü oranda masrafı da artarsa O
gerçek bir büyümediği için Karlı sabit
kalıyor ama masrafları azaltır kendisi
cirosu çok büyürse bu çok sevilen bir
şey çünkü karları çok ciddi şekilde
artıyor onun için büyük start-up
başarılarından İşte şu kadar milyar
dolar kâr etti şu kadar milyar dolar
satış yaptı dan bahsediyoruz ve en
önemlisi sağ koydum daha büyük koydum
yüksek belirsizlik
start-up demek belirsizlik demek
bu Star tatlar yüksek belirsizlik
ortamında faaliyet gösteren Şirketler en
önemli özellikleri bakın Bir bakkal
düşünün fiyat bir restaurant ve hatta
bir sanayi şirketi şu bir fabrika düşün
Bunlar esasında yüksek belirsizlik
ortamında Start atlar gibi çalışıyor
Neden Çünkü belli bilinen Hatta
Yüzyıllardır kullanılan iş modelleri
kullanıyorlar Bakkal düşünün bir malı
alıyor
sergiliyor satıyor belli bir maliyeti
var bir kârı var Restoran alıyor balı
işliyor O da bir şekilde satıyor
müşterilerini fabrikada benzer bir
şekilde Bu da bilmem hiçbir şey yok ama
sosyal medyada şu an çok Sırlan kutusu
kullandığınız uygulamaların çıkış
anlarını şey yapılmış karşılığı yok bir
işte sosyal site arkadaşlarınızla
bağlantıya geçiyorsunuz veya işte Biçer
programı daha önce tam birebir karşılığı
olmayan şeyler bir video chat programı
Dolayısıyla Start atları kendi faaliyet
gösterdikleri pazarları kendileri
yaratıyorlar o kadar büyük belirsizlik
içerisinde de restoranlar hastalığına
bakarım kopyalarım gibi bi her yeri yok
Peki Star toplardan bahsettik sakatların
karşısında kim var Bunlar Tek başına mı
yaşıyorlar ekosistemde Hayır Star
tatlılığın karşısında
bizim geleneksel ekonomimiz var Yeni
ekonomiden bahsettik yerine x dön
geleneksel derken ilkel anlamda
kullanmıyorum geleneksel di
var burada çok modern şirketlerde var
ama start-up gibi olmayan Daha ziyade
günlük hayatımızda karşılaştığımız büyük
şirketler büyük firmalar büyük
restoranlar büyük mağaza zincirleri
Bunlar geleneksel ekonomi
geleneksel Ekonomi ne yapıyor Bu arada
ne gelirse Nikon'un arkadaşlar canım
biraz sıkkın
o Çünkü geleneksel ekonomi için her şeyi
start-up arkada orada olduğu kadar
başarılı gitmiyor birtakım sıkıntıları
var sıkıntılarından bahsedeceğim size
Neden startupların böyle sürekli
yükseldiğinde açıklaması olacak
gerekse ekonomik şunu görüyor dünya
çapında bir en büyük şirketlerin
listelendiği bir liste vardır hiç
Duydunuz mu bilmiyorum Fortune Global
fund Fortune Global 500 dünyanın en
büyük 500 listesi
o Eskiden bir şirket buraya girdiği
zaman çok büyük hayranlık uyandırdı
Derler ki artık o kadar büyümüş ki
buraya girmiş bu adam buradan kolay
kolay geçmez Gerçekten böyle bir şirket
Eskiden forma falandır da girdiği zaman
50-60 yıl kalabiliyor ama şimdi
bakıyorlar son araştırma bu sürenin çok
ciddi azaldığını gösteriyor ya şirketler
orada 50-60 yıl kalamıyor tam tersine
Birkaç yıl kalıp yat 10-15 yılda düşen
şirketler var
Baran bunun karşısında bir start-up
ekosistemi var Belki sizlerde bunun
içinde yer alacaksınız ileride start-up
ekosistemi çok süratli gidiyor bu bir
takım şirketler bu büyük eleksi ekonomi
devamlı düşüyorlar
başlandıktan Star tatlı öyle pazar
değeri var ki bakın
Bugün size bir ölçü olsun Şimdi tatlar
var yunikornlar var Pazar değeri 1
milyar dolar dekak onlar var Pazar
değeri 10 milyar dolardan daha yüksek
İstanbul borsasında şu an
Bu işlem gören en kıymetli şirketin
bu değerinden bir kaç birisi daha büyük
evlerinize hızlı süratli yiyecek içecek
bu tüketim maddeleri getiren firmanın ad
Bu Pazar değil
Dolayısıyla büyük firmalar biraz bir
şaşkınlık içerisinde diyorlar Ne oldu Ya
biz ne yapacağız biz orada tutunamıyoruz
Bir yere giriyor Bizim yerimize oralara
giriyor Bunun da sebebi esasında başlar
geri döneceğim büyük firmalar küçülüp
yok oluyorlar diye bir şey yok çoğuna
bakıyorsunuz bilançoları gay hala çok
büyük Hatta yıllık fazla nominal olarak
yani ciroları büyüyor ama orada
kalamıyorlar Çünkü birileri çok daha
süratli geliyor esasında biraz sabit
kaldıkları için hayat yeterince süratli
bilmedikleri için oradan düşüyorlar
Evet bu da yetmiyormuş gibi bu
geleneksel ekonominin bir sıkıntısı da
var
Bu ürünü takip ederek daha sofistike
hale geliyor
Ama artık Üretim yapmak o kadar kolay
değil Şimdi tam tersine diyorsunuz ya
yeni teknolojiler bu kadar Geçti artık
böyle şeyler daha kolay üretir pek öyle
değil Çünkü bazı ürünler var ki artık
onları tek bir fabrikada üretemiyor
sunuz öyle bir otomobil otomobili
düşünün birkaç saniyeliğine bir
otomobilin Tekbir fabrikadan çıkması
imkansız artık uzun zamandır öyle
esasında Neden Çünkü siz hani
dışta görünen şeyini şasesini
kaportasını motoru vesaire üretiyorsunuz
ama lastiği başka fabrikada üretiliyor
farı başka fabrikada üretiliyor Artık
bunlar da yetmiyor Yani eskiden birkaç
fabrika yan yana gelip bir otomobil
üretebilir di şimdi iş daha zor Çünkü bu
otomobil üzerine dijital teknolojinin
gelişmesiyle o kadar çok teknoloji
bindik ki bir fabrikadaki beynin İsterse
10 bin kişi çalışsın bunu tasarlaması
ünlü Çünkü otomobilin otonom sürüş
özelliği var Artık yavaş yavaş
hayatımıza girmeye başladı su bu burada
oturuyor Kendisi götürüyor bunu
teknolojisi bunu görmesi için radarlara
liderden cihazları ihtiyacı var uydu
bağlantısına ihtiyacı var veya güvenlik
anti çarpışma sistemlerine ihtiyaç
ardından hepsi çok ciddi ileri
teknolojiler onu bırakın elektrikli
otomobil den bahsediyoruz evi batarya
sistemine ihtiyacı var o batarya daha
pahalı bir teknoloji bunların hepsini
tek bir ekibin İstersen bir şey olsun
etini söküldü Dolayısıyla onlarda
ve bu sıkıntıyı Bir de otomobil önemli
bir de uçağa düşünün yolcu uçağını veya
bir savaş uçağını orada gerekli
teknolojilere düşün tekli fabrikadan
çıkması mümkün mü değil
Nasıl oluyor Start Up lar burada devreye
giriyor on Danse bahsedeceğim Çünkü çok
kolay ve süratli çözüm Getiriyorlar
geleneksel ekonominin bir sıkıntısı da
biraz önce de bahsedildi çevre faktörü
sürdürülebilirlik faktöründen
bahsediyoruz ya çok zor bir dünyadayız
Yani bunu çok iyi algılamamız lazım
ya böyle geri [ __ ] imkansız bir
noktaya doğru gidiyoruz
farkında mısınız bilmiyorum Sadece geçen
yazı düşünün Artık tek bir felakete
yaşamıyoruz aynı anda birkaç felaket
yaşamaya alıştık Geçen Yaz Ne oldu
ve küresel ısınma zaten var orman
yangınları
iyi serler su baskınları
3'ü ülkemizde yaşadığımız mü siler Deniz
kirliliği sorunu
var bunun dışında saymıyorum göç peş
peşe böyle
iyi bir takım
felaketlerle beraber yaşamaya alışmak
zorundayız ve bu tespitten yola çıkarak
biz ya 20-30 yıl önce nasıl yapıyor
Duysak nasıl ekonomide davranıyor Duysak
nasıl şirket klasik aynı şekilde Biz
kurmaya devam ederiz diyemeyiz artık Çok
ciddi bir şekilde adapte olmamız
gerekiyor bir takım şeyleri
değiştirmeniz gerekir artık üretmek
yetmiyor
like at kuvvetimiz Sürdürülebilir olması
gerekiyor
ve o üretimin çevreye saygılı olması
gerekiyor aksi taktirde ihraç ederken
takım vergileri tabi oluyorsunuz cezası
var bu
ve bu üretimin enerji kullanması ama
temiz enerji kullanması gerekiyor daha
az enerji kullanması gerekiyor daha az
su kullanması gerekiyor aksi taktirde
cezaya tabi oluyorsunuz Doğal kaynakları
da bir şekilde artık kullanmanın önü
Sırlar geldi Bütün sıkıntılar içinde ne
yapsın yani Bu geleneksel ekonomide İşi
zor abone ol
bu burada işte Start Up lar devreye
geliyor Start Up lar gerçekten çözümüne
itiyor Çünkü Start kapısız artık
yapamıyorsunuz bir otomobilden bahsettim
otomobilin içinde her otomobilin içine
markası ne olursa olsun Onun bir
üzerinde yazan marka var görüyorsunuz o
markayı ama otomobilin içine
görmediğiniz onlarca bazı vakalarda
yüzlerce Start Up lar teknolojik
çözümleri getiren otomobil daha modern
olsun otomobil daha Sürdürülebilir olsun
diye Star topları artık ekonominin
ayrılmaz bir parçası şimdi bize
anlatılan start-up başarı öyküleri işte
ismini vereyim artık Facebook işte bir
arkadaşın hakkına geliyor üniversitedeki
Süper bir şey yapıyor Herkes birbirine
bağlıyor hep böyle tek başına yaşanan
hikayeler gibi anlatılıyor bize Sanki o
kurmuştu şirketi O şirket hani
başkalarıyla çalışması doğru Hayır
start-up lan onun için ekosistem ve
fırını kullanıyorum bak Hem
birbirleriyle en büyük ekonomik
şirketleriyle etkileşim içerisindeler
ha ha startıp ben ben ben inatçıyım Ben
geleneksel adamım ben Star kapsız
yapacağım O zaman ne yapmak zorundasınız
biliyor musunuz otomobil örneğini aldık
ona geri dönerim otomobil üzerine
Entegre Ettiğiniz her bir teknoloji için
en yeni bir personeli şey alacaksınız
personel derken de mühendis çok başarılı
Mühendisler
ve onların çalışabilir boratur
kuracaksınız
daha sonra sabırlı olacaksınız onları
laboratuvarda araştırma-geliştirme
yapacaklar araştırma-geliştirme başarılı
olacak sonuç çıkacak onu ürüne entegre
edeceksiniz ve otomobilin üzerine
takacaksınız bu korkunç virüsü şey
zorluk yüzümüz süratli ekonomisinde bunu
yapacak zaman yok Dolayısıyla çözümleri
sürdürülebilirlik adına da daha çevreci
olması lazım yaptığınız ürünlerin karbon
salınımını daha az olması lazım Daha
teknolojik olması lazım bundan hepsini
Start atlarla işbirliği yaparak
sağlıyorsunuz dolayısıyla bir bakıma
Start atlarla çalışmak zorundasınız
artık Star tatlar böyle marjinal yırtık
polygyny uzun saçlı gençlerin kurduğu
şirketler gözüyle bakmaktan vazgeçme
vakti geldi çoktan geçiyor Start Up lar
ekonominin en önemli aktörleri haline
geliyorlar bu peki anlattım sen bunları
nasıl gelecek bekliyoruz Ya ne olacak
Fabrikalar ortadan mı karşı hiç merak
etmeyin fabrika bizim üretmeye devam
etmesi lazım fabrika asla ama asla
ortadan kalkmış ama Fabrikalar değişecek
o arkanda robotları görüyorsunuz delik
daha robotize olan böyle bir takım
üretim şeyleri kullanmaya başladık
sistemleri kullanmaya başlayıp
dolayısıyla çok daha bol robotu
Fabrikalar olacak Hatta o kadar bol
robot olacak ki
he Fabrikalar karanlık olacak insan
olmayan Tesisler de bakım arkada
floresanlar yanıyor buradan görünüyor
bilmiyorum oturduğunuz yerden o floris
anları yapmaya gerek ancak robotu ışığa
ihtiyacı yok çalışmak için
çok farklı bir üretimden bahsediyoruz
ofis hayatı değişik bir ofiste çalışırız
o da değişir
ben
ofiste çalışanlar tecrübe edenler bilir
veya yakınları çalışanlar O siz
gidersiniz çoğu beyaz yakalı İsa sonra
rutin bir takım işler yapar sabah
Bilgisayarım karşısına geçerim
bilgisayardan internet sitesine bağladım
oradan bir takım birileri alırım onları
bir Excel tabloyu koyarım o Excel
tabloda bir takım formül kuralım
hesaplama yaparım onları bir raporu
aktır yöneticime gönderdim dinle
bu artık bunları tamamen Yapay Zeka
çözümleri yapıyor ve sizin 10-15 dakika
belki bir saat harcadığınız bir şey bir
saniye de yapıyor veya iki saniyede
yapıyor
bu ve zam istemiyor Tatile çıkmak
istemiyor sağlık sorunu olmuyor öğlen
molası istemi ofis hayatı değişiyor
bu peki biraz karamsar bir tablo çizim
size Ama merak etmeyin
bu sürat ve dönüşüm devam ediyor bu
sürat ve dönüşüm geri dönmeyecek olan
bir sürat ve dönüşüm Bu benim odaya işte
Star kaplar sonra başka hayır dijital
dönüşümden size bahsettim ben size
dünyadaki tüm verinin Son iki yılda
yaratılan birini şimdiye kadar yapılan
Hepsinden daha büyük olduğu için budur
geri dönüşü ancak bir süratle ne
olabilir çok daha süratli nereye kadar
gidebiliriz bilmiyorum ama sürat denecek
maalesef
çevre konusunda geri dönüş yok
arkadaşlar bütün önlemleri alırsak her
türlü tedbir alırsak küresel ısınmayı
yavaşlatma şansımız var geri döndürür
soğutma
artık O noktaya geçtik Hepiniz
farkındasınız benim söylememe gerek yok
ve bu değişim içerisinde Start sapların
önemi artıyor Ama artık büyük
şirketlerde uyandı bakın şöyle bir durum
var Eskiden büyük şirketler ne yapardı
yatırım yapar bir fabrika daha çağırdı
işte parası varsa borsadan gider oraya
yatırdı veya döviz alır dışı artık büyük
şirketlerde Start Kaplanı yatırım
yapıyor
Yok ya onlar da farkındalar ekonominin o
tarafa gittiğinden
abone ol
O ilk baştaki mesajıma döneceğim
bu gece köy yapacağız iş ne olursa olsun
yol haritanızı çizerken Bu 21. yüzyılın
Matematiğin iyi anlaması çok önemli Çok
süratli
bir dünyada yaşıyoruz ve siz burada
yeterince süratli bir şekilde yürüyüp
süratli bir şekilde bilmediğiniz
taktirde esasında yine süratle geri
gidiyorsunuz farkında olmadığı
Dolayısıyla
bugün sizlere artık onun parçasız veya
işe girmeyi de beklemeyin İşe girmeden
bu ekonomi parçası haline geldi kabul
edin ya da etmeyin Siz yeni ekonomi
aktörleri siniz Dolayısıyla ne
yaparsanız yapın olduğunuz yerde
kalmamaya bu hataya düşmemeye çalışın
Çok teşekkür ediyorum sağ ol sağlıcakla
tanem